nous sommes bien nées la valeur n'attend
pas le nombre des années
à guéret le jeune garçon illustre la
fameuse tirade du cid ses enfants sont
de futurs soldats du feu avec grand
sérieux et application
ils apprennent tous les rudiments de
leur noble métier c'est l'école du
courage de l'abnégation et de la
solidarité
le capitaine qui les commande va me dire
comment le goût de ce métier vient à ces
jeunes enfants
eh bien je pense qu'il s'agit surtout du
fait que nous prenons les enfants au
sérieux et que nous essayons de les
doter d'un esprit civique et d'un esprit
de sauvegarde vis-à-vis des adultes et
même des leurs et par conséquent nous
donnant une chose absolument concrète à
réaliser c'est à dire secourir son
prochain mais les enfants quel âge ses
enfants entre 10 et 15 ans et nous
touchons toutes les classes de la
société depuis le l'enfant de l'école
primaire jusque même celui maintenant
qui va au lycée on ne devient pas
pompier n'importe comment comment les
formes et vous
non bien sûr parce que nous estimons que
le le métier de sapeur pompier doit être
lié à une condition physique excellente
par conséquent nous donnons des leçons
d'éducation physique et nous faisons une
formation physique assez poussée des
enfants
car si l'on veut secourir autrui on est
obligé d'avoir un corps en pleine forme
et surtout capable de supporter les
efforts et le quel genre de l'exercice
en particulier
eh bien nous ont surtout des exercices
appropriés aux métiers nous les faisons
rentrer et nous les faisons courir
courir courbet lens il avait à
progresser dans la fumée nous leur
faisons des esquisses de coûts à
recevoir pour simuler une poutre qui
tombent ou des tuiles qui tomberait au
cours d'un incendie
nous cultivons leur sens de l'équilibré
en attendant c'est sur un mur et nous
leur donnons de l'assurance en laisant
grimper à la corde ou monter sur la tour
de séchage qui est dans la caserne
est-ce qu'on peut comparer l'exercice
que vous leur fait faire un peu au
scoutisme par exemple euh oui c'est
aussi un mouvement de jeunes qui est
fait par des adultes mais pour les
jeunes et je pense que là nous leur
donnons vraiment quelque chose de de
pratiquer ce qui intéresse énormément
les des enfants puisque il ne ressemble
un peu aux grands comme ils ont les
tenues aussi bien est une femme est
venue de sortie ou leur développer en
quelque sorte aussi un sens civique
bien sûr le la première qualité du
sapeur pompier outre l'obéissance le
sens du civisme puisque les
sapeurs-pompiers se dévouent en
permanence pour leur prochain estimez
vous que certains resteront plus tard
dans vos effectifs
oui en principe que nous avons 80% des
effectifs qui restent avec nous puisque
nous recrutons les sapeurs pompiers à
partir de 16 ans les seules des sections
que nous ayons sont des défections dues
aux aux jeunes qui quittent guéret pour
aller travailler ailleurs
mais si les jeunes restent à guéret bien
nous les avons jusqu'à temps qu'ils se
marient et même encore beaucoup plus
longtemps
mais tous ces enfants qui est qu'ils
vont évoluer
est-ce qu'ils recevront le sait un jour
prochain le baptême du feu eh bien
écoutez oui lorsqu'il 0 16 ans nous
pourrons les prendre avec nous et ils
rentreront dans la grande famille des
sapeurs pompiers
mais en attendant nous refaisons faire
de petits exercices qui simule très bien
une attaque d'un feu et c'est peut-être
cela qui les entretiennent dans cet
esprit
à bora
de reconnaissance avec moi petit lens à
gauche une petite lance à droite
mulet
paul amar
division i see alimenter l aide du
dévidoir aux connaisseurs et abondant et
9 ans
bon
établissez
oui
une vraie
c'est fait
quand ils auront atteint l'âge de 16 ans
ce sera pour eux le baptême du feu la
consécration d'un métier et d'un mode de
vie librement choisie afin que les
servir leur prochain